foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar Beyond
SARS Kobe 2 application of absolute Q
digital PCR system for waterborne
pathogens
I am antonina Salcido of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Thermo Fisher Scientific
to learn more please visit
thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
Hui Yoon Wu research scientist at Tulane
University School of Public Health and
tropical medicine
for complete biography of today's
speaker click their name in the
presenters window at the top right of
your screen
Dr Wu you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone
um my name is
I'm a research scientist at Tulane
University the School of Public Health
and tropical medicine
I'm also from the Department of global
health environmental health
my research area and so on the water and
microbiology and virology
specifically it's on microbial Source
tracking Wastewater based epidemiology
and I studied the faith and transport of
water pathogens and the microbial uh
microbial contamination indicators
um I've been using the qpcr such as the
qa3 and the step plus one system in the
past intensively to detect the
waterborne pathogens and I started using
the absolute Q System since I joined to
learn in April this year it is an honor
to be invited by some officials today to
share my user experience of the absolute
Q digital PDR system for water and
environmental health research projects
where we have been working on in tuning
University
Huawei is important to the public health
one of the goal is to make sure the
water surrounding us is drinkable
swimmable and fishable therefore we need
to Monitor and study the waterborne
pathogens and the diseases caused by the
waterborne pathogens
there are a few groups of waterborne
pathogens in the environment they can be
bacteria such as salmonella and intera
and E coli they can be viruses such as
the hepatitis A norovirus polio virus
adenovirus
um and they can be Proto so such as
cryptosporidium these pathogens that are
usually transmitted from the fecal oral
route since they can be extremely in
high numbers from physics
when the water body is contaminated by
faces or sewage the pathogens can be
transported in water and cause
waterborne diseases
this pathogens can be resistant to
disinfection approaches and some of them
can survive in water environments for a
long period of time
for example crypto is the resistance to
UV disinfection and E coli can propagate
itself in the environment when the
temperature is appropriate
some of the pathogen
waterborne pathogens are noticed which
allows them to break the boundaries
between animal and human and transmit
across the species
the U.S EPA Environmental Protection
Agency has proposed microbial
contamination candidate list
and several microorganisms are listed in
the uh in the tables including adenos
neurovirus salmonella
Michael mycobacteria Avian and so on
these pathogens are selected because of
the diseases and infections they are
causing and they might be regulated by
the federal government in the future
the most most common disease caused by
waterborne pathogens is gastroenteritis
besides this disease adenovirus and
Antivirus can cause the respiratory
illness
mycobacterial Avian and vaginena can
cause lung infections
polio can cause semantic diet meningitis
and hepatitis they can cause liver
disease
among the unit
among the emerging pathogens
viruses are causing 44 percent of the
infections followed by bacteria and
protozoa
virus can infect algae it can also
infect animals including fish bird and
mammals virus can also infect the
bacteria which is also called a bacteria
bacteriophages
for public health concerns
viruses can infect humans these are the
top biases that affect the water quality
and most of them are in the EPA
microbial contaminants candidate list
such as adenovirus the hepatitis A
norovirus
and enteroviruses
it is critical to ensure water
microbial quality for the public health
however there are many challenges to
detect waterborne pathogens in the
environment
some of the waterborne pathogens such as
the viruses that has low infection dose
people can get sick when they are
exposed to a few pathogen particles
especially when they are young old or
immune compromised the pathogens have a
low abundance in environmental Waters
therefore it is not easy to detect them
directly and it is always usually
require us to concentrate to the the
water samples for the pathogen detection
however when we are concentrating the
water samples the Inhibitors in the
environmental samples can be also
concentrated at the same time
the Inhibitors will change the molecular
Target detection in the PCR and qpcr
reaction therefore
to study the waterborne pathogens we
would need to navigate the pathway to
conquer these challenges
first I would like to introduce you some
water processing approaches for pathogen
detection in our lab
the membrane filtration is the most
commonly used method to process water
samples water samples will go through
the membrane filter and the particles
and and pathogens that that are greater
than the membrane pore size will be kept
on the filter for Downstream analysis
such as extraction and then PCR reaction
an application of the membrane
filtration method is to filtrate 100
milliliter of liquid water sample using
the 0.45
micrometer process filter for bacterial
pathogen or fecal indicator detection
foreign
Auto filtration system is a normal water
processing method for waterborne
pathogen
in our lab we use it to concentrate 200
milliliter leak water samples for virus
pathogens
the water samples will go through the
pepper tips and then the pepper tips
will be eluded for the concentrated
water samples and then the concentrated
samples will be ready for extraction
foreign
we use the hollow fiber ultra filtration
approach which is also known as the hfuf
method
because this field a filter column here
it has a larger surface area
in our lab we processed 20 liters of the
secondary elements through the hollow
fiber filter using a peristatic pump and
then we would dilute the filter with the
illusion buffer using the backwash
approach and then the illusion buffer
contains the phosphate and the twin 20.
nanochab hydrogel particles is another
normal approach to concentrate the water
samples in our lab we process 35
milliliter untreated Wastewater samples
with the hydrogel particles
the particles will capture the viruses
based on its membrane Affinity to the
virus system
and then the viruses will be released
after wash and then it'll be ready for
extraction
we use this method to detect the monkey
pox virus and saltco virus from
untreated Wastewater samples and the
main hot water sampling
after the samples are concentrated we
perform extraction for the nuclear acid
and prepare the pathogen detection on
digital PCR here I would like to show
you the procedures that we are
performing in the lab for the digital
PCR preparation
the absolute Q system is similar to
regular qpcr systems such as the step
plus one and constitute 3 in terms of
the reagent preparation
I always prepare the play outline before
I start the experiment
here is an example of the detecting
enterovirus from particles in secondary
experiences
secondary average is a type of tree heat
a waste water before final disinfection
and before it's released to the
environment
we ordered the timers and probe from a
commercial vendor in a dry format
and dilute them with tea buffer as you
can see in the table
the stock concentration is 500 and micro
mode for primers and 100 micromophore
probe
since digital PCR requires a higher
concentration of a primer Center probe
we use the one micron monk for forward
and reverse the primers and 0.25 micro
mode for the pros in in digital PCR
reactions
I usually prepare 200 reactions at one
time and make one make ten antipodes uh
there are 20 reactions in one article
which is sufficient for a 16 reaction
plate
I prepared the primers and the pro but
people makes any posts ahead of time so
that I can sew one early code for one
plate
um even though digital PCR provides
absolute quantification we still run the
samples in duplicate as you can see in
the play outline
um to double confirm the quantification
and we always include a positive control
and negative control in the same place
with the samples
are
enterovirus is an RNA virus and in one
it actually makes we load the 0.5
microliter of the prepared picking mix
and then 2.5 microliter of the one step
digital PCR Master mix which is four
times concentrated from thermal fissure
and we also load the two microliter of
water and five microliters of the RNA
template so in total we prepare the
reaction mix in 10 microliter
here's another play online to detect
monkey pox virus as as an example of the
double-stranded DNA virus
um since monkeypox is the DNA virus we
use the dpcr master mix that is five
times concentrated and the other steps
are similar to the previous play
outlines
we use the same working concentration
for the primers and the probe and we
prepare the people mix in the same
volume
these procedures are to ensure that the
results are reproducible and reliable
after the 10 microliter reaction makes
it prepared we load nine microliters
into the map plate and then we load 15
microliter of the isolation buffer on
top of the reaction mix
we then cover the plates gasket strips
on all of the five columns and load the
plate into the absolute Q instrument
the entire qpcr preparation can be done
in 30 minutes when the lab Personnel is
is proficient and then fully trained in
the qpcr reaction can be done in two
hours which is which is beneficial if
the sample require fast to turnaround
results
here I'm going to share the quality
control acceptance criteria that we
apply in the lab
foreign
micro reaction Chambers are positive
we set different fluorescent officials
for different diets when families use
the the fluorescent Baseline is set for
10 000 when hex of five five sci-fi is
used we studied for one thousand when we
produced is set for two thousand
um as I mentioned before digital PCR
require higher concentration of the
probe so when the probe don't have the
sufficient
concentration 0.25 micro more or when
the probe went through multiple resource
Cycles it can lead to some abnormal
fluorescent levels in the separation
chart which requires a further
troubleshooting
we expect to see all of the negative
controls shows in less than three
positive micro reaction chamber
including the non-template control
processing negative control extraction
negative control
in this controls
if this controls shows more than three
positive micro reaction Chambers it is a
sign of contamination and we need to do
some troubleshooting or we run the plate
we expect to see the total number of the
reaction chamber in one world is greater
than 20 000. and we expect to see the
positive control shows greater than
three positive micro reaction Chambers
for environmental samples
uh as I mentioned before the
concentration might be very low so the
the criteria we're using in the lab is
we consider that a sample is positive
when there are more than three positive
microchambers that are detected and the
more than 20 000 total reactions are
detected all of the negative controls
are non-detect all of the positive
controls are detected and there is a
career separation in the back graph
if one of the items did not pass we
would need to rerun the samples
so for the digital PCR provided as the
absolute quantification and I would like
to show you some examples of the sample
so we completed in the lab
I tested some virus pathogens positive
controls on absolute queue I accepted
the DNA from Human adenovirus uh human
agino virus 40 virus is stuck from uh
for calcium control
we purchased the G block standard for
enterovirus coxsack keep
neuralized G2 hepatitis A
um for positive control they all show
the very clear separation
and we set the threshold for uh 10K the
green that are Big Dice and we set the
threshold for 2000.
I also texted some bacterial pathogen
positive controls on absolute Q these
are the separation charts for computer
vector and salmonella G block standards
um these are two pathogens in the EPA
CCR list and then they are Quantified
with different fluorescent dyes as you
can see they are in different colors too
um by by using different dyes uh this
can provide a potential to run them in
duplex in the digital PCR system in the
future
I also tested some viral physical
indicators
positive controls on digital PCR
there are 3x 174 and MS2
bx174 is a single stranded DNA virus and
the MS2 is a RNA virus they are both
both bacteriophages
um the positive controls the nucleic
acid acts extracts from the virus stock
the absolute Q system enables such to do
Multiplex the plates which allows
running several targets from the same
sample on the same run here I would like
to show you some examples we completed
in the lab
um in this place we we tested the hf183
IAC AC for the standard the hf1 history
is a human fecal indicator it is a human
host specific bacteroidism
recently the U.S EPA has drafted a
method 1696 for its application to
quantify vehicle contamination from
human waste in Environmental water
samples
the method proposed a internal internal
amplification control which is the IAC
here
so that the PCR inhibitor can be
identified at the same time the sum the
fecal contamination levels is Quantified
which is a duplex
we applied this essay in absolute Q
system successfully and here is the
separation chart
we use the fan to quantify the fecal
contamination level and the week which
is the Green Dots here to identify the
inhibition level
the internal amplification control
transmit is is expected in the reagent
mix so if the samples are inhibited are
not inhibited the week
quantifications should be similar to NTC
and in this way we can get both absolute
quantification results of people
contamination and the inhibition at the
same time
we also apply the soft code to
commercial kits on the roadway store
examples that we extracted directly
the teach has three targets inside and
we can quantify South Coast 2 and 1 Jin
and two Gene at the ppmorgan together
the the PM move is a plant balance and
it is found to be the most abundant
virus RNA virus in human physics
here it is used to quantify the uh for
the for the quality of assurance in
South Coast to exit from Wastewater
besides the absolute quantification the
absolute Q system can provide a
sensitive quantification and I'm going
to show you some examples that we have
completed in the lab
in this project we are trying to find if
there are virus pathogens associated
with the particles in secondary elements
for water reuse purposes
since the secondary effluence is treated
Wastewater the concentration of the
pathogens might be too low to detect
the particle Associated virus is a
portion of the total virus so it might
be even more challenging for the
detection
um in this experiment we process we use
three liters of the secondary efferent
samples and then we process it by the
membrane filters with different pore
size
on the digital PCR we were able to find
a positive well with the 0.5 Gene copy
per reaction
and then we factored in the qpcr
preparation volume the nuclear acid
volume that we load in the reactions
which is the five micro liter and then
the extraction volume and Sample
processing volume for for the back
calculation
after we do the back calculation we
found that the concentration of the
human adenovirus associated with this
particle is 60
copies per liter
we also detected the Norovirus from the
secondary effluence particle samples as
well for the final concentration of
272 copies per liter
and also we found the enterovirus from
the secondary reference particle samples
the sample 7.3
um has three positive micro reaction
Chambers
and it is Quantified as 0.34 copies for
my colleague here
um as I mentioned in the QC of QC
criteria which can still consider this
sample is the positive since it's
greater than three uh positive
microchambers
and then after back calculation we get
the final concentration of 45 45 copy
per liter which is the detection limit
of the sample processing method that is
combined with the digital PCR
we detected the monkey pox from raw
waste water samples
so in this project we processed 35
Norway store to 35 milliliters always
water samples using the nanotrop
hydrogel particles
and after that calculation we found that
the concentration of monkeypox in in one
sample is the
3100 copy per liter
and and then the by the the final
concentration is greatly influenced by
the concentration factors and the the
sample processing method we are using
above all uh is my experience using the
absolute Q digital PCR system
um we can get to the absolute
quantification of the waterborne
pathogens without developing a standard
curve and then the
absolute Q system has similar procedures
to prepare the reagent mix compared to
qpcr so and then the experiment can be
completed in two hours
um the detection limit is as low as the
0.64 copies per microliter per reaction
which corresponding to
1500 copies per liter or 45 copies per
liter in Environmental water samples
depending on the concentration Factor
um we could also use the digital PCR to
evaluate PPI inhibitors for the samples
finally I would like to acknowledge the
support that my team has provided to the
project to the projects in the in this
presentation and then the research is
founded by the EPA star Grant and by U.S
Navy
thank you so much for your attention and
I'm happy to answer your questions now
thank you Dr Wu for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now and we'll answer as many questions
as we have time for
now let's get started
our first question is how did you
determine where to set your threshold
values
um thank you so much for your attention
and for your question so uh as I
mentioned in the uh in the in the
presentation we have choose several
different dyes to detect the pathogens
this is also allowed us to be able to do
duplicates or Multiplex in the future
um and then because different dyes have
different fluorescent signals this is
the required us to do some some positive
wrongs and negative runs to
determine the the threshold level
uh basically we would compare the
positive
signals and then see where the the
separation appears and then compared
with the negative wealth so for fam uh
in our lab we see it is consistently
showing the separation around the 10 000
K signals so we stay with the 10K for uh
for for the firm dice that we use for
the pathogen detection and it has been
working pretty well in our lab
um but when when people are using a new
essay it is also recommended to do the
same procedure compare the positive
control and negative control and then
determine the threshold level and stay
with the same threshold level for the
same Target
yeah and then the same thing applies to
other fluorescent dyes
great thank you for that
um another question here what is the
dead volume for the reaction
um so in uh in the absolute Q menu it is
mentioned that the debt volume is five
percent so that means like um uh 9 over
95 percent of the reaction makes that
weight load in the plate is used for
quantification
um however in our lab we only have one
digital PCS system and we cannot compare
across the platform and we don't have a
super significant concerns of the
reagents that we loaded into the um into
the plate that is being used so I would
stay with this less than five percent
number for now
um and then I I think if we see some uh
some differences in different platforms
we can do further investigation and then
comparison
thank you and some good questions coming
in here um the next one is where all of
the concentration methods comparable or
was one better than the other
so this is a very good question
um we we study environmental samples uh
especially the water samples in our lab
and depending on the types of water
samples and the types of
um
basically depends on the the
characteristics of the samples we would
have to choose different concentration
method as I mentioned the the membrane
filtration is the most commonly used one
because of the uh the cost the uh the
level of training we need to provide to
the to the new fellows in the lab
however there's also a very very limited
concentration factors so therefore we
have to we have to adopt different
methods for different Target that's why
we introduced the Innova prep system to
detect viruses and then we are also
change what we were trying to use the
hydrogel Beats for the uh for for the
raw waste water samples to capture the
viruses and other pathogens in The
Matrix
so I guess uh there's no short answer
for for this one it depends on the
concentration Factor you are looking for
it depends on the uh the samples you're
working with
um yeah yes thank you
all right thank you
um the next question here is while dpcr
is more resistant to the accumulation of
Inhibitors do you think the additional
cost and reduced well count associated
with the technique makes it a better
option over qpcr
so I think uh in from my experience the
reason that digital PCR is more
resistant to Inhibitors is because of
its low Sensitivity I mean High
sensitivity low detection limit
which means the samples can be diluted
more and still be able to detect it
um um I have I I still need to do more
comparisons with the uh inhibition
levels using the hf183 like I mentioned
in the in the presentation we have
established the essay in the digital PCR
but we still need to use this essay to
quantify the inhibition inhibition level
for the samples
um and also I think in terms of the cost
uh uh as more and more people are using
the digital PCR platform the cost will
reduce in the future like the sequences
nowadays for us so
um I guess the cost will be compared
terrible eventually in the future with
the qpcr system
the only concern I have besides the cost
is the support throughput but I'm I'm
I'm I think I think uh people are trying
to uh increase the throughput of the
digital PCR so that we can do the
quantification in a in a larger batch
great thank you we have time for a few
more questions
um someone said thank you for a
beautiful presentation
and is interested in the virus recovery
method used if you can speak a little
bit about that
yeah thank you oh yeah so um we have
tried uh different concentration method
uh and we we found that the Innova prep
and um and uh
Nano nanotrop hydrogel beads they both
have around 20 percent of the recovery
in terms of the virus pathogens uh we
did that by comparing the direct
extraction and the concentrated
pathogens so um I guess Mike ends is
around 20 percent is is what we found
from the samples
thank you I'll wrap up with this
question why did you choose five
microliters of DNA or RNA for the
reactions
so uh for for the digital PCR that we
are using here in to land uh the we are
loading uh nine microliter in the wells
but we we prepared 10 microliter for the
reaction mix
and then out of it we use the five
microliter the reason we use five micro
leader is uh we uh the pathogens are
usually hard to detect so on one side
the more DNA RNA you load in the
reaction makes the higher chance you
will get to the pathogens
um but the the other side is uh since
the samples are usually uh uh containing
the Inhibitors and after the
concentration method the Inhibitors are
also accumulating so the more samples we
add the more Inhibitors we add as well
um so we chose to five microliters as
the like the sweet zone of the of the
balance from the detection of the
pathogen and then the the consideration
of Inhibitors in the in the in the
samples
um however if you look back to my uh my
uh my equation or the play outline uh
for DNA Target we added to my
coordinator of the digital PCM Master
mix and 0.5 microliter of the pp mix
which gives the room for 7.5 microliter
of the DNA sample so uh we can you can
still play around in the system to
choose different numbers for your result
and then
um uh as long as we can we can get to
the uh the sweet Zone that we are
satisfied I guess you can choose
different volume as well
great thank you and thank you again Dr
Wu for your time today and your
important research we'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor Thermo
Fisher Scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast
and before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
do not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on demand and libraries will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay and we encourage you to share
that email with any one of your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
bye